はい皆さんこんにちは道元です今日は友達
のマットに来て来てもらっていますマット
のことを知らない人が何人かいるかと思い
ますので最初に自己紹介をしてもらいたい
と思っていますはいお願いしますマット
です日本語で日本語のイントネーションと
いうのを教えてますよろしくお願いします
イントネーション」っていうのは日本語の
皇帝アクセントのことかなまあそうなんだ
けど日本人ってだいたいアクセントって
言葉を使わなくて日本
イントネーションで言うからそっちの方が
伝わるかなと思って
まあ普通はそうかもしれないけど俺の視聴
者のほとんどが実はアメリカ人だから普通
に
肯定アクセントで行った方がいいかなと
思う日本語で喋ってるじゃんいやそうだ
けど今日本のどこに住んでるんでしたっけ
今大阪に住んでんだけど
昨日の夜から別府について
昨日の夜じゃなくて
昨日の夜
まあ大阪弁では
昨日って言うからまあ間違ってないそうだ
けど日本語の
皇帝アクセと
イントネーションを教えてるよねだったら
標準語を使うこんなに突っ込んでてさ道元
が一番関西人や関西人
じゃんあーダメだ
ついに英語のお出ましかんそれが何かいや
道元って焦ると英語出るんだなと思って
焦ってないしだって
どこに住んでいるかもういいから笑いを
変えよう話題じゃなくて話題ねまじ
よだき夜だけ道元も方言使ってるやんだ
から使ってるじゃん
大阪すんなことないよねないけどなんで
こんな人間ちっちゃい人大阪だったら絶対
やっていけないなと思ういやお前よりは
大きいからな体だけなライブケツには
IneeduseEnglishthe
日本語
じゃなくて日本語ね